not to pick on magnus carlsen but
another commentary video from the world
blitz chess championship another magnus
carlson loss
the moves were played quickly and what
we see here is sort of an unorthodox um
queen's pawn game employed by rajabov
and carlson decides that's that's enough
of an excuse for him to get aggressive
out of the opening place c5 bishop e2
we're headed toward a little bit of a
typical structure
in that uh we're likely either going to
get an isolated queen pawn or a hanging
pawn structure after knight b to d2
carlson fee and kettles rather than
keeping the bishop on this diagonal
really a heads up play honestly because
the bishop is so much better here
targeting the d-pawn after bishop d3
bishop to g7 castles we see the position
we have on the board and carlson rekha
rovkas as well rook to c1 is played
pretty quickly by rajaba if and carlson
takes a moment to think because he's not
sure how he wants to approach the
central structure does he want to take
now and invite the hanging pawn position
knowing that dynamically white will have
a little bit of a space advantage but
then he has targets long term to focus
on
does he want to take some other approach
maybe developing a little more passively
and leaving the tension for a while it's
a critical decision but ultimately one
he decides is one that is left for a
better day with b6 because by putting
the bishop on b7 he gets a little bit
more prepared to deal with this coming
hanging pawn structure double fee and
kettles are usually pretty good to deal
with hanging pawn structures because the
bishops are coming at the diagonals from
both sides of the board
and again
what you want in those structures
white's going to want to keep the minor
pieces on the board at least until the
pawns can do something tricky and nasty
whereas black is going to look to
improve the knight likely from c6 to
either a5 or sometimes f5 to open up
diagonals and to increase pressure and
we're going to look for the dynamic
tension to build until something happens
with these pawns in the center rajabov
decides it's good to just put rooks on
open files hey everybody knows that
bishop to b7 and then a3 is runs into
rook to c8 everybody's sort of just
staring at the tension here right it's
like a game of chicken where kevin bacon
gets his shoelace caught in the tractor
which ultimately proves that he wins the
girl moral of the story don't get caught
with your shoelace and a tractor
now uh after rook to c8
the problem for developing your pieces
when there's pawn tension still in the
center is you have to know where you
want them long term like you can't just
put the queen on c2 if that ends up
meaning that the c file is critical so
for java is trying to anticipate what's
going to happen with the structure
before playing queen to e2 which creates
a concrete threat perhaps to take on d5
and then gobble up the a6 pawn carlson
decides he can no longer sit around and
wait and must do something in the center
before white gets everything he wants
takes on c4 we get the hanging pawn
structure we've been foreshadowing this
whole time makes sense for white
and now both sides will have to think
about where they want their pieces to
deal with this the hanging pawn
structure is instructive in many ways
it's very dynamic both sides want
different things white has a space
advantage and wants to keep it that way
black wants to look for the right way to
get the pieces hitting the pawns because
as we said they're hanging they can only
be supported by pieces no longer can
they be supported by pawns and that
makes them positional targets for the
rest of the game
now rajabov is going to think here he's
not exactly sure what to do so he plays
a high class waiting move a move that
frees a back rank for future problems
maybe takes away the g4 square who knows
maybe he's going to play g4 if he wakes
up on the wrong side of the bed next day
black plays queen to c7 clearing the way
for the d file queen d7 is also an
option and white plays queen e3 a 97
comes that knight's headed to f5 as we
foreshadowed coming this way is usually
also an option but after 95 excuse me we
don't see 95 just yet there goes carlson
catches up with us right hey magnus
speed up a little bit for us buddy we're
making a video here
white plays well after knight f5 white
has to think about it because it's a
critical moment do i want to leave this
knight hitting my weakest pawn on the
board or do i part with the bishop pair
nobody's ever happy to part with the
bishop here just ask stockfish but
ultimately i think it's decided
correctly by rajab that this knight
hitting the d-pawn is going to create
too many tactical problems and you'll
notice that he decides with the
aforementioned option to part with the
bishop here the only other option that
might have been considered was queen of
four but okay we're not going to have
time to analyze that he takes e takes
structurally from a structural
perspective we favor white with the past
d pawn and black double pawns but again
black has this monster of a bishop over
here on b7 and things things are going
to get real here in just a minute if
if white isn't careful about the tactics
on the diagonal
this felt like a game that was headed
the direction for carlson as as usual
but
after things get messy here you'll see
that critical opportunities are missed
knight d to f3 makes sense it's a solid
move that re-coordinates the ponies
brings them back to where they like
where they like it protecting each other
and uh carlson decides the bishop pair
will no longer be of value to him he
wants to take on f3 so that he can put
this knight into e4 not exactly sure
it's the most uh the best decision and
from the bigger picture perspective but
the position is probably just about
equal and both sides still having plenty
to play for similarly to what we've been
saying they're playing for black wants
to gang up on these weak hanging pawns
and and white wants to keep the dynamic
tension and the because as long as the
pawns stay together they're also
restricting black's pieces correct so
yes they're weak but they're also an
asset that's the funny thing about
hanging pawns black played queen to d6
and now rajab slides over creating
tactical tension and believe me
everybody it's about to get real bishop
takes e5 was played because carlson was
afraid of tactics on f7
and uh in this position
after queen to c6 we had queen to e3 and
then the rook comes over to d8 it looks
like things are headed the favoring of
black with a strong knight on e4 and the
rook's recoordinator but don't forget
that long-term weaknesses aren't going
anywhere grab a snickers these dark
squares may end up being a problem if
this pawn ever gets out of the way
rajabov thinks similarly so he plays f3
maybe by getting rid of the knight i can
prepare opportunities to push
after playing e6 he says it's worth it's
worth a pawn for sure if i can just open
up the dark square diagonal time to go
to sac town he'd love to put the queen
on e5 or c3 or even h6 and carlson has
to think remember this is blitz
everybody not a lot of time to make
sense of these tactics
what we will do in a moment is back up
and talk about a critical moment that
rajabov maybe maybe missed but uh in the
current position
carlson is still thinking didn't quite
jump in with the opponent yet
again if knight takes you have to deal
with ideas like queen to e5 if rook
takes you have to deal with ideas like
queen to h6 or queen to c3 are both very
dangerous pawn takes would be a mess as
well because now you really have
long-term problems on the dark squares
after thinking for a long time you'll
you'll just be ready for the fact that
carlson jumps into the square on d3 with
the pony maybe preparing originally to
get rid of the dark square bishop and
make a trade
but uh with with a little bit of a messy
messy uh mess of it in terms of what he
calculated it's where the game
ultimately unravels knight to d3 is
finally played where job off is thinking
he's thinking he's thinking i look like
john lennon i look like the uh the the
top chess player from the band the
beatles if any top chess player looks
like someone from the band from the
beatles it's me i think i look like john
lennon that's exactly what he was
thinking there that whole time believe
me
after rook to d1 we are waiting for
black to come up with the correct move
that unfortunately carlson does not
he plays a move that you'll find it was
the right square wrong piece the correct
move for black was f4 x-clam of iauchen
after queen to e4 trading queens would
have eliminated the chances for white to
win on the dark squares and ultimately
head to a drawn ending however carlson
does not go for that and instead he
played knight f4 as we said good square
wrong piece looks fancy with the tactics
but after rookie one rook takes d1 and
taking e6
we're gonna we're gonna find that uh
white has too much on the dark squares
the best the best and last chance for
black before we get to this knight takes
e6 blunder was the move queen to c5
trade in queens he just underestimated
how dangerous white's attack was
to be completely frank about it and uh
needed needed to get the queens off the
board in a hurry he didn't he played the
move knight takes e6 and after queen to
c3 f6 all of a sudden it becomes very
clear what's going on and actually
white's attack is just out of control
rook to f8 is played desperation time
the queen's going to go gobbling pawns
and with a couple of forcing checks
we're going to find that carlson's
position is simply simply not a holdable
holdable mess king to h1 nothing like a
nice strong prophylactic move when when
you're on the attack queen takes c4
bishop e5 the king is in a little bit of
a net carlson's down on time plays rook
f7 but that's not enough after bishop d6
jack king e8 and queen over pieces will
be lost it's only a matter of time
bishop takes f8 if rook takes by the way
the queen hangs carlson plays one last
desperate move but bishop to b4
discovered check as mate in the next
move
now
as we said
the critical moment for carlson was
perhaps playing the move f4
instead of the move knight to f4 would
have held of course he had one last
chance trying to bail out into the end
game but fun fact because we love to
learn around here this is this is a
video for chess.com after all right is
that back in this position here as much
as i liked this tactic and talked about
the pressure it was bringing and
ultimately it made carlson part with the
dark squares rajab had a tactic of his
own right here if you want to pause the
video we are under 10 minutes which is a
magic mark for me hey i never finish a
video in under 10 minutes so i'm real
proud you can pause the video and see
what rajab could have played no you
don't want to okay i'll show you rook
takes e4 was the move that maybe would
have won on the spot f takes is met by
things like queen takes f7 but even f6
would have allowed c5 followed by
sliding of the queen and the move d5 yes
is this really tricky to see yes would
have been
probably impossible to solve all this in
a blitz game yes but we love tactics as
we said and we love the idea that past
pawns end up being victoria's you know
why because who doesn't love an underdog
story thank you everybody for watching
and subscribe to us everywhere this is
chess.com appreciate appreciate the
support
you